macho macho und damit herzlich konnten
die leute ich bin heute wieder für euch
am start mit einem neuen video leute ihr
kennt bestimmt alle den gedanken den
sicherlich einige von euch wenn nicht
sogar die meisten von uns schon mal
hatten
man wacht manchmal morgens auf und denkt
sich dicker wäre mein leben nicht viel
leichter wenn ich einfach mehr geld
hätte genau um das thema was heute mag
immer leute denn wir ziehen uns heute
mal eine video dokumentation über das
leben von einer 17-jährigen reihen die
in eine eine million euro villa wohnt
und generell das krankhafte luxusleben
überhaupt hat und wir schauen mal wie
sich so damit lebt jetzt kommt ihr
eigenes haus für 1,4 millionen dollar
besitzt handtaschen dem wert von
mehreren hunderttausend dollar und
vätern 200.000 dollar luxuswagen
okay okay ja das ist das ist nicolet
gray sagt uns die beschreibung niklas
grell geht als verbündete teenagerin
amerikas berühmt wurde sie weil sie in
einer talkshow in tränen ausbrach weil
ihr taschengeld von 5000 auf 1000 dollar
monatlich gekürzt wurde
ja also den kollektor erst 17 jahre alt
und wohl einer der verwinkelten teenager
der welt hat es aber nicht gereicht
die leute oder witzig mache diese
reaktion auf einerseits einmal deutlich
ein bisschen so drüber ablästern können
wie solche krank verwöhnten teenager
leben andererseits sind wir auch mal ein
wort darüber verlieren können damit ich
mal sagen kann aus meiner perspektive
wie wenig ab einem gewissen punkt geld
mit dem tatsächlichen glück im eigenen
leben zu tun hat ist hab ich nämlich
eine sehr wichtige messe für alle da
draußen die noch nicht arbeiten oder
nicht solange drei monaten worunter
teenager an diesen bei eigenheimen ein
geschenk von ihrer mutter über 200
quadratmeter auf kurze frage warum trägt
sie drinnen high heels ich meine ich bin
man so das letzte was mich in meinem
leben beschäftigt sind frauen schuhe
aber das ist sogar mir aufgefallen
wieso die gerne aufpassen dass so zehn
zentimeter trägt erstmals seit dem 18
wahrscheinlich haben die 1000 euro
taschengeld nicht ausgereift ein
geschenk von ihrer mode
über 200 quadratmeter auf vier
stockwerken gerade platz genug für eine
collette designerklamotten und luxus
handtaschen leute material material ich
werde ich werde einerseits wie gesagt in
diesem video wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
sogar ablästern wie drüber dieser
lifestyle ist andererseits will ich aber
und das ist ganz wichtig dass ihr
versteht dass das nicht aus einer
perspektive von neid kommt das aus einer
perspektive von ihr wissen im
verständnis von menschen kommt sagen
dass die leute das ist nicht das was
glücklich macht glaubt mir ich kann euch
jetzt schon mal an der stelle sagen ihr
werdet mit 10.000 euro die ihr euch
selbst verdient habt wo er quasi schweiß
blut und tränen rein investiert habt und
wisst was sie wirklich wert sind
glücklicher als mit einer million die
man schenkt genau so untypisch wie diese
bude für einen teenie ist und verläuft
auch nicolet alltag
ich hoffe auf bestellte mir dann
frühstück weil ich nicht den kaffee es
also mal im ernst leute das kann man ja
auch wirklich von keinem menschen der
verlangen alter das man im jahre 2020
noch ins café geht der gleich glaub es
hackt selbst teenager die von immenser
armut bedroht sind okay und mit 17 in
einem nur mehrere millionen nicht mal
milliarden teuren gebäude leben das
ihnen gehört ja und nur 1000 euro
zwischen elf monaten selbst diese
ärmsten der armen unserer gesellschaft
sollten nicht ins café gehen müssen zum
frühstück das sollte ihnen geliefert
werden manchmal lässt sich aber auch
dort
wir können wie können wir das still
dafür davor sitzen dazu schon leute wie
können wir das als menschen machen
unsere mitmenschen sind am leiden
da muss ich was unternehmen ich glaube
ich könnte man muss manchmal es sich
aber auch dort dann schminke ich mache
meine haare oder lasse sie machen
er wurde wird sollte ich sag's euch
jetzt ich sag es euch es gibt unter
garantie da verwette ich mein linkes
auge drauf kinder die sage mal in
südamerika zum beispiel in ärmeren
gegenden in ärmlichen verhältnissen groß
werden die tausendmal glücklicher sind
als sie weil ich sage ich mal eine sache
die ich glaube ich im leben verstanden
habe und das ist wirklich nett wie ich
finde es ist wichtig dass man sich
selbst als mensch ein ziel gibt okay
eine sache nachdem anstreben kann irgend
ein orientierungspunkt in die richtung
gehe ich in die rechnung gehe ich das
will ich erreichen das ist sowas von
wichtig im leben finde ich so und dann
hast erzählt eine 17-jährige die hat
schon alles welchen sinn hat ihr leben
ist wirklich so was meint ihr wie geil
es ist jeden morgen frühstück zu
bestellen wenn man das seit drei jahren
macht aber nichts im leben zu tun zu
haben das kotzen noch an wie konter- und
teenager so ein luxusleben leisten und
wer war nochmal ne cola cola und zur
erinnerung vor knapp zwei jahren sorgt
der teenager weltweit für schlagzeilen
in einer us-talkshow danke danke nochmal
für die bilder der us-talkshow nächste
das ist wirklich die haben nicht so
viele kameras darin mit amerikanern und
die auflösung ist über nicht so ganz so
ernst also auf die frage gehen wie kann
sich das leisten natürlich wird sie
reiche eltern haben irgend jemand
dahinter der sehr sehr viel zeit in sein
eigenes geschäft sein unternehmen
gesteckt hat und vielleicht ja ich sag
mal so stereotyp ich bis zu weniger zeit
und seine kinder deswegen die kinder
sehr viel geld und wenig aufmerksamkeit
haben was letzten endes man muss es
sagen vielleicht von außen gut aussieht
aber glaube ich gar nicht so ein geiles
leben ist ich möchte dass seine mutter
versteht dass ich von 1000 daher nicht
geben kann
ich habe einen bestimmten lifestyle
geben sie mir nicht wegnehmen kann
man schon dass da sieht man schon dass
das läuft schon so viel schief hörte ich
hab' ich habe kein kind gut wisst ihr
wahrscheinlich dass ich ein kind aber
leute ich habe auch nicht ultra viel
ahnung von erziehung aber soweit
verstehe ich so den menschlichen kopf
die menschliche psyche schon dass man da
einfach sieht dieses mädchen denkt sie
hat einfach gewisse dinge im leben
einfach so verdient ohne irgendetwas
dafür zu machen
und das sind nicht sogar irgendwelche
sachen sondern das sind eben 5000 euro
monatliches taschengeld sie sagt ja
meine mutter kann mir das nicht
wegnehmen
doch kann es ist nicht dein geld ist das
geld deiner mutter kein mensch hat ein
anrecht auf 5000 dollar taschengeld aber
das schreckt sie nicht leute die lebt in
so einer welt wo sowas
selbstverständlich ist und das ist so
giftig als man ihr in der sendung zu
einem job verliert sie die fassung
oh mein gott leute oh mein gott das
müsste ich mal kurz das original suche
nicht ich will mir das gesicht zu sehen
okay okay alles klar also man muss auch
dazu sagen tab hat dass sie ein bisschen
zusammengeschnitten ja also der beitrag
wo er sagt dass sie mal arbeiten soll
und das weinen der nachrichten so drei
minuten ca auseinander
aber der punkt bleibt leute es ist kein
schönes leben zu glocken sollte ihren
berühmt-berüchtigten auftritt kennt die
welt nicolet gray als verwöhntesten
teenager und doch anscheinend hat sie
den rat beherzigt denn mittlerweile ist
die youtube sorry aber nein also bei
aller liebe ich weiß nicht ob youtuber
der richtige job ist um mal so die härte
des lebens oder zumindest mal ein gefühl
dafür zu bekommen was man eigentlich so
alles hat leute weil weil darum geht es
auch darum geht es nämlich auch wenn man
kindern es gibt das gefühl gibt alles
ist selbstverständlich dann ist das so
gefährlich weil die kinder damit so eine
erwartete an die eltern gehen sozusagen
also von meiner mama und mein papa
kriege ich immer alles so ohne irgendwas
zu machen und ohne selbst zu arbeiten
jetzt will ich aber auch von dir ohne
irgendwas zu machen aufmerksamkeit von
dir ohne was machen liebe und ich will
das alles meinem leben läuft und das
mache aber so läuft seit einfach nicht
das führt zu so viel frustration und
unglück locken
ich habe immer noch mein altes bett kein
neues gekauft hat total finde ich gut
dass dieser das schafft nicht zu weinen
ich sage euch noch eine sache dazu leute
es gibt sogar wissenschaftliche studien
die untersucht haben ab welchem punkt
geld nicht mehr weiter glücklich macht
oder wie sehr geht unglück
zusammenhängen und diese studien
herausgefunden dass ab einem punkt ab
dem man quasi alle sorgen wegen schulden
wegen unsicherheit in der zukunft sich
erstmal vom hals halten kann wenn man
dafür genug geld verdient ab dem bringt
mehr geld nicht mehr glück
ok ich weiß nicht vielleicht wird es da
17-jährigen mehr bringen wenn sie mit
ihren eltern in einem haus lebt als
alleine in eine million wähler zu wurden
obwohl nicolet stolzer 1,2 millionen
abonnenten auf youtube hat erscheinen
ihre soko laut eia bei der läuft ja hier
nicolet grave digger läuft der kanal
läuft weiter das war okay immerhin
immerhin macht sie ja schon was schauen
was selbst ja obwohl nicolet stolze 1,2
millionen abonnenten auf youtube
erscheinen ihre sozialen kontakte im
echten leben eher überschaubar zu sein
noch ein weiterer punkt dafür um einfach
glücklich zu werden im leben leute was
macht glücklicher ein großer
freundeskreis mit leuten über den man
das gefühl hat haye die mögen nicht
wirklich so wie ich bin ich habe mit
denen so ein gefühl von vertrautheit
wenn ich mit den rädern fühlt sich
einfach alles so an als wäre alles okay
und ich fühle mich einfach aufgehoben
das oder keine freunde und 900.000 euro
handtaschen sammlung taschen und
handtaschen klingt klinken statement von
einem recht unglücklichen menschen no
joke und nicht leute ich will auch nicht
zu leicht machen
das ist sogar die erste reaktion sie zum
beitrag dieser haha ja ich hier im dorf
in buxtehude lebt ja viel besser als die
und das kann man auch nicht sagen
die wird sicher einige sachen in ihrem
leben erleben können die wir niemals
erleben können sie hat sicher mehr
freiheiten als wir in vielerlei hinsicht
aber es bleibt einfach dabei dass
menschen relativ ähnlich gestrickten so
menschen brauchen beziehung um glücklich
zu sein so ihr braucht freunde braucht
familie ihr braucht vielleicht ein
freund oder der freundin dass das macht
glücklich arbeit zu machen der mann sinn
sieht in der man gut dass das macht
glücklich was für ein trauriges teilt
mit dass das weil der handtaschen sind
nicht meine freunde nicht wie die lustig
aber ja das hat mir mal und in den
kommentaren was ihr davon haltet ihr
euch vorstellen das video auf die oben
könnte meinen kanalproben ist kostenlos
und würde mich sehr freuen
ich bin schnell raus bleibt stabil
bleibt reich tut